thank you
glowing through the Cayman Islands
Hurricane Ian offers a taste of what is
about to come for Cuba and the US
mainland the Island's National Emergency
Operations Center has now given the all
clear as Ian heads across the Caribbean
we may have to turn around
the International Space Station showed
the eye of the storm as it approached
Cuba
with winds reaching 155 kilometers per
hour it made landfall in the West
there's a risk of widespread damage in a
country already suffering an economic
crisis
then in Ian's path is Florida it's more
than a century since a storm like this
last threatened the Tampa Bay area
I think you're always worried when there
is a storm coming your way so we're
doing the best we can to prepare and if
you need to pull evacuate all right
we'll evacuate if I need to
the problem here is that storms
approaching from the south push huge
amounts of water up into the shallow
Tampa Bay inundating homes and
businesses with a storm surge up to
three meters high
many people decided to head out of town
rather than enjoy the hurricane
though sitting tight stocked up before
heading home to batten down the hatches
with Ian approaching the U.S Mainland
federal government has declared a public
health emergency for Florida that has a
population of 21 million people
Bernard Smith Al Jazeera